okay hello everyone we are looking at uh
open language design review part about
incremental language development
series and we have a variety of topics
today
from index functions
so we have Ed here there's kind of a
collection of function repository
functions that deal with
getting the index of things like tuples
or going from tuples to an index value
even a canonical ordering
which element of the canonical ordering
is this right and there's a whole kind
of class of these and you know they are
reasonably popular in in function
repository and so my general thought was
is there some way to generalize this to
a
index function or indexing oh yeah
here's a question how does this relate
to laser computation
because
one is the subset of the other
like not everything can be indexed
for sure
right
but
okay
so
I mean
basically what you're suggesting is some
kind of language construct where we're
saying
um you know let's say we have this
and we have you know
comma 20 let's say
and then
we want to get that is the base object
am I making sense
my question is what is the nth thing in
that base object
yes right
um
and
it's an interesting
I mean so
in some sense
um
well let's say that this was called
something like come
uh
um
well
in some sense
what we're looking for
is that right
it's the don't divide the reverse yeah
or compute that part
or
the other thing is position
in
this
of oops that's annoying
of
you know whatever it is
whatever
okay so those are the two so sorry it's
not obvious that lexicographic also is
always the best one for indexing
I see what you're saying
I think it is with these five though
but there might be somewhere Lex Ola is
not ideal
right
so in a sense
that the more complete form would be
a um
uh
you know
sort
into favorite order somehow
I mean that's the thing we're trying to
represent
all right
yep yes yes
now
some of these functions probably have
various options what's an ordered Tuple
what do you mean by that
is that different from tuples
yes it's basically a
tuplesless sort uh applied
which sort applied to individual tuples
and then
[Music]
okay but so do we not have a top level
function that generates that list
I don't think we do but the code's
really short no I understand it but but
I'm asking is this a useful thing to
have
I use it quite frequently
so I mean this is basically
a
you know sorted tuples or something
of
zero one two comma
um
what's that what's that thing there what
does that mean
s people said three elements yes
why isn't it just comma three
because
sorry yeah I assume it's the same as
normal tuples yeah
so I am confused normal tuples is not
documenting
oh it should I see I see I see I see
it's just a one element version of what
would otherwise be a multi element by
the way we should probably promote this
this case
to the um to the top here I mean I
certainly use it with some frequency
okay got it
um
okay in any case
I see okay
all right so so the the other thing is
to have a function that generates this
nice and efficiently
right what would you call it
I mean it's sorted tuple's right name
guys
that's good ordered two polls
why did we order tools what does it mean
order tuples
the same as sorting
okay but is that obvious enough what
that means to that it isn't just shorten
the outer list I mean it's the um
um
what is it distinct tuples or something
but that might mean something different
as well
set tuples that sounds wrong
um
anybody
I tend to prefer sorted tuples
um we don't have a lot of I think we
have sorted entity classes the only
sorted head we have in the language
right now
okay what does okay let's pick on some
people
Ed Christopher Brad
opinions
it's probably best to look at the
literature
well take a look I mean
I I think sort of tuples would probably
win out though because just because it's
so easy it's so obvious from a
Mathematica standpoint what that would
mean
fine all right okay so first point is we
got a new function sorted tuples does
that make sense to people
yep
um
and okay then the next
thing
is how do we do this
right
um
let's see let's have some ideas here
come on am I do I really have to be the
one saying everything here
Brad Christopher somebody Ian
Rick
ideas
for all of these combinatorial items
that would support indexing that could
be an option to what's already in
Mathematica
what are you talking about what what do
you mean
for example with uh with tuples if you
if you had like a indexing option
that couldn't work because
I mean for ordering it could work but we
can't return one thing returns one Tuple
and the other return no
right so there are some functions like
subsets for example where I think
there's a usage that you can effectively
use to get uh you know this subset with
index whatever
yeah the last usage
right
so I mean right I mean that would cover
the from index cases if we had stuff
like that and all these functions which
I'm not sure we can but well let's see
if we can I mean so let's say tuples as
an example right so okay so subsets
you're saying that we can perfectly well
say so this is the this is the case
where you have a list
and we say
what's the end spec
it's how big the subset is
okay so let's say all comma
and then let's say here
the thousandth subset
cool
and that's a take spec which is kind of
nice
don't you think
yeah I mean the only well the only thing
that's slightly annoying is the fact
that it comes back in a list but
whatever
yes and that's that's probably livable
with because the value of having a tech
spec is probably exceeds that
but when sometimes wants to reverse
I know I know so let's think about that
like that seems like it kind of has to
be a different function because it's
just that you know it's it's fundamental
arguments are just totally different
um well as we just said subsets of an
integer assumes it's an index now that
doesn't even work because you need to
yeah
right so so then this
will be okay so let's just try something
here
find index
this is perhaps crazy
okay
this might be crazy but I mean this is
this is saying do we have any function
that works this way
I mean it's sort of like first position
of range
kind of like find instance right
it is yes
you'd have trouble if like the first
item was permutations of uh range 20.
why
because 20 factorial is a big number
but never ever did
I see
but it's a it's a strange syntax yeah I
mean wait are you proposing this as
another function that might be useful or
are you proposing this is the way that
you expose the the you know subset index
that's what I'm suggesting I'm
suggesting that the
the subset index is like solving an
equation
I'm suggesting what we try to look at
you know indexing
you know let's look at the other
functions see whether they could have
something like subsets added to them I I
just think it seems like the level of
magic is quite high and unless we're
going to have some whole sort of solving
apparatus where you can have nested some
kind of nested situation where there's
an algebra of it it doesn't seem like
there's much Point again you have to
evaluate the range sometimes you don't
have to evaluate the first argument so
all right
okay but the alternative here
would be to have something where
I mean
how do you generate
you have to have something that says
what the universe is that you're looking
at like subsets of range of 10 comma all
right I mean you have to give it all the
arguments that you'd give to subset and
then you give it the the index
the element
um
right
uh from index to index uh could have a
list of supported functions coming
material functions
but again the weird thing is you have to
give the arguments for those functions
too you can't just say from index of
subsets you have to say from index of
and then give it the whole subset spec
ific see this has proved rather nice
where you can have that cellular
automaton disembodied on its own
and then
an operator form here right I mean this
is this is the lazy version of things
would be subsets returns unevaluated but
you can map over it and you can fold
over it and whatever and then of course
you could symbolically ask it what the
position of some index is but obviously
that's not how subsets works
except that in the things we've been
talking about we have a concept of lazy
subsets right
that's what we're talking about for the
lazy stuff correct
I think there's a lazy subsets yeah
But but so in particular
if we did this
maybe we solve both problems by just
going through the laziness business
right because we we have essentially an
unevaluated subsets by setting it up as
lazy
is there somebody who knows what we
where we got to with the lazy design
Avery do you know I don't but I can ask
well but who who's who's dealing with
that
I'm not sure I think it was Kristen in
the past
no no no no but we've had much more
recent meetings about it yeah about a
meeting within the last few weeks so who
was who was pmming that
um
let's see there's a packlet on the
packler repository is that related
yeah presumably
this lazy list function this this far
was from 2014.
where is our more recent stuff here
I'm checking right now
I'm essentially certain that the right
way to do this is using this lazy stuff
because that's going to have
well we were talking about Christopher
do you remember you were in that meeting
I've been in several of the lazy
meetings yeah you know what do we think
what what do we think that the um
what is the category
oh it's in the multi is it in the
multi-computation
it it was yeah
oh so that might be in a different area
hold on
I think it was for a long time in there
but now I thought that like Roman and
Leonid were doing things related to that
and I'm not sure that's under the
multi-computation stuff
okay
I don't even know where it is but I mean
I I think I know roughly I mean I think
basically the stuff there is that
there's a
there be a generic kind of lazy list
generator kind of uh object and you know
you can make one that generates subsets
and I think I mean I don't know
there's some versions of that where
you know you generate this you make this
generator thing but you sort of don't
really remember how you generated it or
what generated it so you might have this
generator which is sort of a big block
of code but you don't necessarily know
it came from a call to subsets in which
case it would be hard to then do this
but I think most of the versions that at
least like Leon and Roman were looking
at do know that like oh this generator
whatever you want to call it
comes from a call to subsets uh and so
you know you can my recollection is that
we have a generic function lazy list
um
and uh
that there is a generator and that you
know that there are a few certain
functions for which there are lazy
versions
which can act as generators of which
subsets is an example
right and then you may see any of the
constructors kind of lazy variants
right and all five of these would count
as that but you do need the underlying
algorithm
sure for example permutations requires
Lamar codes
we understand that there needs to be an
algorithm
it's not just generic
but I think that's the right design is
to go through the lazy system and
probably also
I mean
going this way round it seems to me that
adding an argument to tuples which is a
take spec seems worthwhile to me
does that make sense I mean so then
you mean subsets right here
and then permutation let's take a look
at permutations whether that has you
might also want to look in the details
of tuples because some of these
functions have undocumented or like
they don't have a usage line for their
an argument form okay
seems to be clean okay yeah
okay so then so that seems worthwhile I
mean you know Ed's algorithm just seems
like it seems like a worthwhile thing to
put into tuples doesn't seem any harm
um make it consistent with subsets
right it's not my algorithm though I
stole everything
okay okay fine they're all well known
that looks clean as well
looks good we should add it in there now
what's standard order
foreign
numbers we did those uh three years ago
well that's a different function okay so
this is go ahead hold on
let's just summarize what we're talking
about here okay so we've got one
function
which is so let's let's summarize our
new functions go ahead Michael there's
one more that we need which is probably
the second most important I think is
intertropolitations
yes I agree okay so hold on sorted
tuples
that's a function right now let's look
at integer partitions
oh boy
oh I see what we've got here
and partitions so then all we have to do
is make that a text back
okay
so this case
would need to be generalized to a text
back
that makes sense are you sure those are
actually take specs where you can give
like a span for example
I'm not sure but it will be good if they
were
okay so then
here we have adding
a
take spec
argument
um and so that would be added to tuples
you know one zero twenty comma
and then this would be I think this is a
nice way to do it actually I really do I
think this is a perfectly reasonable way
to do this for this way around
which is I think the more important way
around
thank you
this first one
corresponding count function
what's that mean oh I see I want to go
over all this 10 to the 12 which I
succeed in four days but I need to know
how far my index goes
foreign
well that's interesting because that's a
separate thing okay so wait a minute
subsidiary functions
um
how big can the index be
and then uh
which index
does this element correspond to
but by the way just in terms of how big
in this index be that's also something
that would be useful for like cellular
automata indeed indeed I keep on getting
bitten by that
also where error messages are they've
improved quite a bit in the past recent
versions where if you put in something
too large it will basically return that
it's too big I know I mean
there are two more next time previews
because sometimes but you can do form
index to index it is computational
prohibitive to do it but you can
immediately go from one to the next
right
I know
I mean
you know again that seems to me to be
something which you know that that needs
to be part of the lazy system
right there might even be a general
you know General stuff in the lazy
system for asking at least for the next
one
right but how big can the index be
obviously it's easier in the lazy system
it's just length
well no it's very hard I mean in general
length you can't answer length because
it might be infinite
no I understand that I mean hard to
compute but actually in a cellular
automatican case The Annoying Thing
there
is you know if there's a rule number
you know let's say something like this
how big can RN be
so it's not really the length of
anything no I know it's not it's not but
I think I it's a related thing where I
think there might even be like an error
message where if you give it something
too big it'll just tell you here's the
number yeah I know so you know in the
past I've done things where I'm just
like oh like put in some astronomical
Lumber and I look at what it spits out
of Max is yeah right
you know I'm also guilty of doing that
one
yeah
that's wrong we should just give a
message in this case
because if I actually give a concrete
thing here
I'm fairly certain it will give an error
yeah we should we should change this
Brad I think you I mean you might be
about to be the keeper of this function
well we had actually talked about this
rule issue in a previous meeting and I'm
not sure where it got written down
okay well Avery maybe that's for you to
go chase because I think this
I I think you should just generate an
error message in this case
um and is that going to be a good enough
solution as opposed to creating a whole
new function that tells you what the
matter is a great solution but it's a
minimal solution it's at least we get
that yeah okay separately there should
also be a whole new function that tells
you what the max rule number is right
but I think what we what we really had
we had a specification but it never got
implemented
called Rule space data
although what you're suggesting here is
that that's a more General function but
the problem is without a lazy version
you know I just don't know how we get
this
and this thing like how many tuples you
know tuples one zero twenty
you know how long is that list that
seems like a kind of a separate problem
see what I'm saying from the cellular
automaton case
they're not that different I don't think
no but but in terms of language design
they're different
because this one you've got a concrete
thing what you're trying to do
in this case
is
you're trying to compute
you know
whatever it is you're trying to compute
as if
you're trying to compute this right
really you're trying to compute that
right you don't want to actually write
that but that's what you're trying to
compute
see what I'm saying
whereas in the other case there's
nothing to write down that you're trying
to compute is that
so I'm saying I mean if we had a
function called cellular automaton rules
I know what it would even do you know
and it just gives a list of rules right
then it would be again a length thing
but otherwise we just don't know that's
kind of what rule plot is supposed to do
right
no it isn't no I mean no no I'm saying a
list of possible rules like for the
elementary cellular automata would just
be numbers from 0 to 255.
right although that list could be very
very large indeed and and if you're
giving real numbers it's going to be
very totally uninterested right so
but the problem is we're trying to solve
the problem of how big can RN be
in this case
um
it is already a solved problem isn't it
I mean maybe not for every possible
specific I mean the code has this
information in it the question is how do
we how do you get it other than by
generating an error message
you know what I'm saying
that that's the question now
we also have these forms of cellular
automaton that are based on an
association
and maybe in that case we can
I mean
again
and Turing machines and so on I kind of
like this rule space data idea which
could be a brad function
I think this is a separate problem okay
let's let's just review where we're at
here
we've got one definite thing which is to
put in these index algorithms
as the selectors in tuples and these
other functions agreed
anybody
okay
okay then
we've got
my opinion is that all this other stuff
should go into the lazy business
because I think it's you know it's total
mess to be introducing functions to do
these rather obscure cases
so
and you know
this will also be accessible from the
lazy system but I think it's convenient
to have it accessible here this makes
sense to everybody
and I'm like oh you know you had you had
said one more thing
Ed
okay we've got sorted tuples there's a
new function
new numerative function now you're
saying the standard order index
you are proposing that as another
standard
um it was uh this was very useful for
your uh project but I don't know whether
they're used enough that we should uh
bring them in well what are they
uh there's a dude open up the details
and options it's somewhat complicated
it's sort of like a combinatorial greedy
function
I mean I remember why I needed these but
that's
I mean this could just stay as a wfr but
does it have a name standard order index
is not going to be a name that's going
to survive
be more descriptive what is it
uh well there's standard let's see it's
something you would have to be something
dealing with standard order
what is I think there's a intertra list
in the form missing
what do you mean
in the traditional standard order I
think would be the clear named
given the integral this give me the
index of its standard order what is an
individualist I mean you mean
three four nine seven
the individualistic list of integers
okay but
this applies to any
list right any if I had a hundred in
there I would get a standard order index
for it
right it's like curdle numbering of some
kind it goes on forever it doesn't it
doesn't it's not just like
you know get me the position at the
index of this in the permutations it's
like given any integer list what is its
index correct uh no it only works for
for lists that are already in standard
order
yeah okay
what wait what is standard order
uh starts with one uh contains
uh one through n basically and there's
particular rules so that yeah is it
supported this sounds way too specific
it's very specific okay then let's not
worry about it then it's that's a good
place right but somebody else in this
family that is of relevance would be
directioners it's a
explain
like for the classic uh Condor like
wolves I would like to know
419 over 517 what is its number if I
would sort the version is right
uh
it takes a take thing for furry sequence
yeah that's what that would be I mean we
don't have much for the ferry sequence
right now correct
and we probably should
because I agree it's a common thing do
we have wfrs for the ferry sequence
it's wrong you know why is this not
working
oh come on what's this doing
oh it is a built-in function
what is that very sequence
what does that one do
what does it do for it gives you all
this once with the maximal denominator
so why isn't it
oh I see it's excluding the ones which
reduce
yeah
oh there already is a take element
in this particular case there is
yeah here the problem is not so much the
syntax but it it first makes the
sequence and takes it out so it doesn't
work for large numbers this thing here
so it's an algorithm problem yeah that's
that's a question for Ed whether that's
solvable
okay
yeah I would have thought there was an
algorithm for that yes
I think it's called oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah I know those things
Stern broco trees or something yeah
well that seems like a very bad like
algorithm too
right sounds like that's a that's a
thing to do here is to make this more
efficient
okay can we should we move on from this
item
yes
sounds good very silent today
we have a few people missing yeah
and deep thinkers I was playing with my
previous meeting well ran long but I'll
try to be more vocal now
okay generally you don't have too much
trouble with that
that's uh okay
and body simulation
but we don't have Rob Knapp here right
that's right I asked to see if he was
available and didn't get a response we
could bring this up later if you want to
move on the other topics
well let me explain something that I was
realizing
um
right this is the algorithm what what do
we use for the current hot sphere gas
thing do we use the auto log n
algorithm or not
no I not at the best of my knowledge
I had no idea that Etienne had worked on
this
even the hard Square code that I wrote
probably doesn't use the order log in
because you have to do some smart
cue management or something to get the
fastest possible code
I had completely forgotten or maybe
never knew that Etienne worked on this
maybe maybe you could um
but I just just
why am I using Safari
Safari my God
um
let me see I'm just going to send this
I had no recollection that this was a um
uh
okay any case
hmm
the thing that I was
thinking about
um
my gosh where did this come from where
did all this material come from Michael
pulled together a lot of the references
um
but yeah
there were many many more yeah this is
just kind of a sub sampling of different
considerations that go into handling
hard body problems I mean there's no
question that the event the Newtonian
event change is the massive benefit of
choice for hearts fields
okay that's interesting so that's an
event
yeah and I think that barring this issue
of the possibility that
you know as many spheres as you want can
Collide or circles can Collide at
exactly at the same time
then the Newtonian event chain thing is
something that people have already
figured out how to do pretty well
okay but but then
you know most of the people who are
doing this
are not looking at the question of
you know exact generation of randomness
so they never cared about the
multi-collision thing I understand I
understand
um
boy this thing I've certainly written
about at length but probably nobody's
ever bothered to read it
um if uh I might recommend
um physics engines have gotten big in
gaming
it'd be good to grab whatever's free and
incorporate some of that
do you think the physics game engines
use the event Chains No no definitely I
don't think so either and in fact some
of them are quite approximate and like
you know do weird fake stuff because
it's just a game
right but but there was some project for
a while of connect making some
connection to physx which is in videos
yes I know I know I don't know what
happened but yeah
I mean the the whole virtually any
people
that deals with hot spheres as again
quality pointed out there's some kind of
thermodynamics so you you generate large
ensembles of trajectories uh than derive
your thermodynamic averages or baby
correlation function then do some
backward analysis that your numerics is
good enough
because everything is our directory will
be totally formed
yeah I understand I understand so that's
solving a different science problem from
the one okay look look here's my point
of view here that to me the hard sphere
gas is a minimal version of an
agent-based model in some sense
and the way I was thinking about it is
you know to what extent is it true that
what matters in the agent-based model is
essentially the causal graph
of which agent interacts with which
agent
which in the case of hard sphere gas is
determined sort of geometrically
yeah
but I mean we've tried to make a design
for General agent-based modeling
and I mean Christopher you and I have
looked at this several times
um
does anybody know where that where that
uh material is by any chance
there's one more problem that people
solve or two more one is basically pure
purely mathematical showing the the
limit of certain hot sphere things goes
to a bird's money crash but this is all
very mathematical physically and the
other one is given the locally confined
cluster with initial velocities what's
the maximum number of conditions that
can happen
that's an amazing question
I mean
yeah it's time to Infinity yeah so they
can fly away
yeah I understand I understand I
understand it's kind of like how long
can it rattle around yes exactly
and it's the answer to that known
bounce yes
how big are they
oh big
exponential
I
didn't be so careful with the papers
right okay where is our stuff where is
our design fake
anybody know
I'm not sure it was ever particularly
far along
no but there is some stuff that was
written down
I think there is a dedicated meeting for
it once yes yes there was
and I think
the only question is where
is it
in um let me just look here
Alice
some random notes Here
okay
I don't know where these are but we have
some random notes
SW notes modeling
Okay so
I got that
this was the idea of just general models
okay
the heck is this
right okay so that didn't get very far
there
Okay so
my basic claim is
what matters is I mean is that true for
General agent-based models I mean
generally you don't think about like a
self-gravitating gas
as you know that's an end body
simulation but it's not an agent-based
model usually agent-based models have
discrete events is that a first
statement
I think so maybe I mean I I I would say
that it should count as an agent-based
model but in practice people doing
agent-based models are much less precise
and they don't usually
yeah they usually
right
continue
with other agents
Ian what is this thing you just sent
through for the
what does this have to do with I'm sorry
what is this about is this about the
ferry sequence let's turn brocade tree
that was from a while ago
okay so you're saying that that will
what should I run this yeah
okay do we have a function in the
function repository for making Stone
broken trees
uh yes fusk fusc
in the function Repository yes
why the heck is it called that
uh it's
um because it looks like obfuscated code
but it's uh it's famous for being called
flask
wait a minute you're saying our function
repository has a function called fuss in
it is that what you're saying and that
and and they need examples of those so
you can generate
um that tree okay but that's not the
relevant thing yeah that's not the
relevant thing we're not interested in
that we're interested in a function
where you can where you know that you
want to generate that tree and you have
a function that generates that tree
right we're not interested in it being
in the neat examples of some other
function
am I making sense I mean that's what I
was asking do we have a function that
generates who's you know well you say
you know Stern brocot tree or something
however it's spelled and it generates
that
is the answer that yes or no
yes we have that too
so in the function repository we have a
function
let me look it up really
we have that function
[Music]
I don't think so
it seems to be a numerical function so
it gives you a sequence not a tree
what is going on here why is that search
look at this what the heck is doing a
very another thing for you to go Trace
okay
it says zero items and finished
okay so we don't have this function so
how about we you know since
Ian has a one-line version of it maybe
he could put it in
okay
and I have no idea what this is
I mean this is no doubt amusing but I
have no idea what it is
okay I'm sure I've seen this before in
some way
I mean that's kind of interesting
actually
is this is this easy to compute what the
what the nth term should be
I don't remember them I'll take a look
okay it seems like nobody is awake today
I I'm I'm not okay so
with respect to these asian-based models
and hard sphere models
presumably what we want to do is Define
something which is analogous to the way
that multi-way systems work where you're
basically saying you've got
these you know you have okay so it's
kind of like
event based well actually we could just
add a section here
about quotes agent based agent based AKA
event based
models
okay what basically what's going to
happen is
the the confusing part is what we've
already got is various functions that
take
you know an A and A B that are both
pattern objects and say let's say they
give a c and a d and then we are doing
on a set of elements
these are subset Replacements does that
make sense
anybody understood the connection
between that and agent-based modeling
because it's saying
if you take you know a fox and a rabbit
you know a is a fox b is a rabbit
anywhere in the system a fox and a
rabbit combined for the fox to eat the
rabbit or something
that's an event right so it's saying
given that there is a pattern
of
two elements let's say
then there's an event that combines
those two elements and gives you
something different
that's the idea now sure I mean in
general just a function needs to run
when an event happens right if you if
you've registered that I care or when uh
foxes meet rabbits or when foxes are
within radius whatever of rabbits run
this function when that happens and that
function presumably you know
does whatever it does exactly so so the
only thing in
sort of interesting I hadn't really
realized this before but in our generic
token event graph formalism and so on
we're just saying there is an arbitrary
bucket you know in in a general token
event graph
you know it's like given
a
bucket of tokens
of a certain form
here's an event
that happens from them
now in a typical
you know in these multi-way systems it's
like we look at all possible events that
can happen from buckets of tokens that
match the pattern
am I making sense
whereas in typical of agent-based
modeling I assume that that's a Monte
Carlo thing
is that a fair assessment
Christopher do you know yeah I think so
yeah
right so so we've either got
um
you know
in general
we make a multi-way system from this
or we probabilistically pick one path
okay it could be difficult to make a
multi-way system because some of the
branching ratios could possibly be
uncountable
but both that and the fact that
realistically I mean often the you know
right often inside of these functions
where you know okay the fox is within
radius the rabbit and it has a n percent
chance of eating the rabbit you know
people Implement that stuff kind of
naturally with like random Choice sure
no I agree I agree I the multi-weight
system is a rare case to want to do that
mostly it's probabilistic
right but I understand the function you
know I I'm not like we could design the
whole functions that at each step you're
expected to kind of give all the
possible outcomes and probabilities
associated with them but that's hopeless
yes
I think it's hopeless but but I think so
I think this is going to end up being a
you know it's going to essentially be a
random you know what's actually going to
be as a you know a um it's essentially
going to be a random instance let's say
we had sort of agent based model
right the the only difference between it
and something like a random instance is
that
when you have a random instance because
there's Randomness like in the code that
that the system is running if that makes
sense as opposed to being in the user's
code right I mean if you run Nest list
you can put something in the function
that that calls random real and it'll be
non-deterministic we don't call it
random next list
I understand
I understand I see what you say right
right but it just says I see so you're
saying the agent-based model has the
randomness in it right I mean it's the
same as if you give an arbitrary
function for cellular automata you can
put Randomness in it yep
okay so so hold on so let's
uh but the other thing that we okay so
one thing we need is
uh okay so motion EG for a hard sphere
gas
you know how well do we model motion
right so one case is everything is on a
grid
one everything is on a grid
and motion is just EG
move one square
case two
is it's genuine Newtonian motion so to
speak or Genuine whatever you'd call it
Galilean motion I don't know what
yeah but there should be something
in between one and two
like that that has to do with the
discrete approach to continuous calculus
perhaps okay
so you're saying
well okay genuine Galilean motion or a
finite difference version of this
okay so what we're saying here is that
in the end
see what's what's complicated here
is that there are events
okay basically the point is that events
can potentially
uh give
both
you know a resulting X
and x dot
I've entered that
how do we enter that oh whatever
um
does that make sense
Yes except for it doesn't if you just
say there's two things are going to
happen it doesn't seem to include the
possibility of a branching Factor
right I I think we're ignoring the
branching for now like I think that
because again the randomness will be
inside of the functions it will not be
done by the
practice
I think in general right I mean in
general you're going to have to from
each event you're going to have to
return some whole spec whether it's some
kind of object or whether it's an
association or whatever that basically
gives all the the actions that are
supposed to happen because there's a
whole set of you know oh kill this agent
or create a new agent or move this
direction or move to this position
etc etc you know change your color to
blue I mean there's a whole list of
kinds of General things you might want
to do and we're going to have to have
some you know object for representing
them or something oh yeah but that's one
thing which is the state of the system
and then
the state of the system has I mean
basically there's a global state
and then what's going to happen is
that
there's a function that says how to pick
up parts of that Global state
you know
picks up parts of the global state
modifies them and replaces them
right
I I think that's the basic operation
sure I mean I think that they're going
to be many functions though because
you're gonna I mean right for example
you might want something that okay it
modifies the global state it you know
you're you're modeling your foxes and
your rabbits in it every step you want
to randomly spawn carrots you know
everywhere right because the carrots are
growing
but then you also want functions that
have access probably to the global state
but also to certain kind of event
specific local state so something like
oh anytime a rabbit encounters a carrot
you know run this event and then you
want to be given the rabbit and the
carrot and then you want to be able to
to tell it something about you know
modifying this local situation like kill
the carrot and make the rabbit you know
more powerful or something so so are the
carrots agents
probably yeah
are the sticks agents everything is an
agent it's an agent-based model
no but I mean the the issue is you've
got a big list okay the basic point is
you've got a big list of Agents
and you're told how different agents
combine to make other agents
not really I know we're trying to go
with that but I think not really there
are some models that are of that form
but there are lots that aren't
okay well there are models where you
create where you have a big bang all the
time where you go you know nothing goes
to carrots
right I mean I think I think in practice
it's just going to be that there's going
to be a list of Agents you know and and
and the agents are going to have
you know the agents are going to
basically be arbitrary objects they're
probably going to be associations with a
bunch of properties like you know how
well fed is the rabbit kind of thing uh
and then there's also going to be a
bunch of framework properties that they
have which are things like their
position you know
Etc and and the reason why that's
important to be in the framework is that
presumably we want to be able to have
things like
you know you want to be able to specify
the boundary conditions and stuff like
that in a general way in the framework
and so then it would manage moving
things around and so on right the point
is that for example
the
sort of
motion is a is sort of a built-in thing
the idea of space is a built-in thing
but little else has built it
I mean the idea of
um
you know the concept of space
that the concept of space can probably
be built into the update function
whatever the update function is
what no this is the point that there'll
probably be many there'll be many
functions that that will you know happen
in all sorts of different events I mean
there'll probably be some that happen at
every step regardless and all the others
that are event specific and then each of
these functions will return things about
you know move my agent this many squares
this way and then the framework is in
charge of managing that and knowing how
boundaries work and stuff like that
but if you take the extreme case of a
hard spare gas
where
the agents do nothing other than but
then they have to compute when their
next event is that's the non-trivial
thing well no I mean the the the I mean
this would be a bad way to implementing
a hard sear gas model but I think
basically what you do is you'd have your
agents and say at every step you know
apply this function to the agent and the
function is look at your velocity and
move that direction okay and then you
have an event that says if two agents
hit each other or within some radius of
each other then compute new velocities
that is not the event chain algorithm
that's more like yeah
I mean that that that's an algorithm
that'll get the wrong answer when
they're you know when it gets very
crowded they'll be weird singularities
they'll be weird you know overlapping
nonsense but you know right that's the
zeroest way to do it and if you had
infinitely small steps then you'd
basically be okay
right but but my point is that for the
function we're trying to implement
arguably we should just try to okay then
we we're actually breaking these apart
the hard sphere case is just a separate
problem from the agent yes definitely
definitely I'm just saying it's right
you could do it as an agent-based model
but but it's it's in the same way that
with the end body simulation you know
self-gravitating gases it's just there
are much better algorithms for doing it
more accurately without having a
bajillion you know infinitesimal step
size and so on all right okay it's a
one-off okay so now the next question is
end body simulation the existing
function we have can we put from a
design point of view can we put hard
sphere gases into it
well I mean maybe we should talk about
systems that are having continuous
events versus discrete events because
the the event chain thing is just saying
okay we can write down
um a list a list of actions to take on
the state space and you know for the
hard sphere gas we kind of know what's
going to happen there will be
propagation events interspersed with
Collision events but but we never need a
Time step because we can just keep
solving equations of motion
exactly but whereas for an endbody for a
gravitational and body problem you never
escape gravity the the events are
happening instantaneously all the time
right
but what I'm saying I mean presumably
maybe somewhere in this picture of
space-time there are gravitons flying
around yeah yeah yeah but we're not
dealing with that level we're just
dealing with the the modeling at the
level that people think of modeling you
know inverse Square law and so on
right that's a that's a whole different
thing I mean yes the the you know the
thing that for example Jonathan has been
building for discrete gravity simulation
does that type of thing okay even more
extreme than that type of thing but the
question that I'm asking is if we were
to just say right now we have this
notion of you know inverse Square
harmonic Newtonian coulomb is there any
reason we can't add hard hard you know
hard sphere to this
and the algorithm will be different
right for that case we probably wouldn't
have a very good
output of it because we don't have when
could probably shoehaunted in a
appropriate interpolating function but
it's not our natural one
yeah I mean maybe hold on hold on hold
on hold on I want to think about that
for a second okay what about
interpolation order zero oh
interpolation order
you're saying that one yeah one no I'm
not feeling about interpolation order
literally the the interpolating function
object
but what's wrong with it if the sphere
there's nothing wrong with it but but
the one form that comes from andesoft
has certain ideas about smoothness that
are not fulfilled
but why isn't an interpolation order one
which specifically isn't smooth
I mean it doesn't have to come from ND
solve
right
so I think it will be a linearly linear
interpolating function which would it
seems to me do the right thing because
it would be between you know between
collisions it would just be kind of
linearly changing I think
well that's a question I mean will that
that's a question somebody should needs
to work out is Will
interpolation order one
I mean Brad this is something since you
understand the and body thing now
um perhaps you could answer that
question I mean my perspective on the on
this is that
the like an iterator based code that is
taking time steps is going to have one
type of output in the event chain thing
is going to have a different type of
output and what you would be asking for
within body simulation would be more
like the time step output so if you do
any interpolation at all you've already
destroyed the natural outputs I I think
I think we have a misunderstanding if
you scroll down a little bit on the
right notebooks even like the internals
of this and body simulation data would
be totally different for event chain
based result then foreign
it could format the same summary books
but what's inside would be a pretty
different thing
which will be fine and then the plot
of that thing would be something that
you get from a an order one
interpolating function this is a
technicality yes
right but so so what you're saying
Michael is that inside and body
simulation data could be an event chain
or the result of an invention
fine
right
but what does what would the output look
like what the output is right here
oh okay
all the information is invisibly inside
right and the only thing you get to do
is to ask questions about it like what
is its position
right so what this would be is packaging
up I mean you know we could do this even
right now with our existing algorithm
for embody simulation which isn't the
best um for hard sphere simulation which
is not the best one I'm asking the
question with this design right could we
have something which basically says here
uh
you know
this oops instead of this
just says you know hard sphere or
something
right
is there anything wrong with that
if we assume fully elastic
smooth surface yes
I mean they're in the dusty Cuts Fields
they are of course there are many kinds
of hot spheres I understand but the
generic case I mean just like we don't
have to have you know we could have a
relativistic correction to the Newtonian
potential but we don't
I mean you can specify it but but that's
a I mean so you know the next question
is just like you can have an arbitrary
potential there for the you know named
laws there could we have a an arbitrary
thing that plugs into the event system
possibly yes
well I think that's the way to get
around this issue with having multiple
collisions actually
because if we if you allow it to be user
specified then the user can say what
they want to do when they get to
multiple collisions
yeah okay
but the the other issue was
do we need a message when there are
multiple collisions
for practical applications
is not really a credible case I would
say
uh yeah I don't think so either but you
know when we were doing the work for the
upcoming blog that we saw it all the
time
right but that's this is one of these I
mean there's also yeah right there's the
issue when you have high enough density
you end up getting just just weird stuff
right I mean like I guess I was gonna
mention I mean because we're talking
about embody simulation and and
collisions and stuff I mean another
feature that might be nice that's
vaguely related is having a a collisions
version of the gra you know
self-gravitating thing but but the the
the the problem is there is again like
it you often end up with if you end up
with a big clump of self-gravitating
colliding things you end up getting
weird little singularities that make
everything explode every so often and so
on it's it's kind of hard to to solve
those
right
well I mean
okay look the parts that we seem to be
on are
you know can we parametrize the hot
sphere thing if we make an event
uh
you know an event list version of that
um
can we
you know we can put in the hot sphere
case the pure elastic hard spheres which
is the most useful case and we could do
that with our existing code
well does does the existing code have
good enough
Precision handling no it does not the
existing code is no good for that
however as a way to understand the
design and to get something rather than
nothing it's better than nothing Stephen
what would you do it would do machine
precision and or it would okay yes yes
it will do crummy machine precision and
it will get it right for some number of
collisions and that will blow up
but it will do it you know in other
words for many purposes that's perfectly
sufficient
you know if you really want to know
exactly what given hard spheres will do
well good luck preparing the initial
state to 300 digit precision
right it's one of these things where
just like like it's all unrealistic yeah
so I mean you know but it is very useful
to have even approximate hard spares
they show up in just all kinds of models
no
and so that's what we should do is take
even our existing wfr code and just put
it in packaging it in this way
now what we'll discover is that some of
the things that we have in the wfr code
for hard spheres like causal graphs and
things we don't have here because we
never needed that it doesn't make any
sense to have a causal graph for a you
know an inverse Square law
that makes sense
yes yeah yeah it makes sense but but
also
the causal graphs can be obtained by
just transforming whatever the output
data is
fine fine I mean that may be a
specialized thing the only of interest
does
but
you know for the agent-based models
thing
there is presumably a causal graph of
relevance because there are discrete
events and they affect each other
presumably I mean presumably we can draw
that causal graph for what it's worth
but it seems to me like go ahead it may
take a little more thought about whether
the events are instantaneous events or
if they're like discrete time and
evidence
right well this one has instantaneous
events but it's in continuous time
whereas Christopher is saying that for
most of the agent-based models people do
they're in discrete time is that a fair
statement
yeah I think so yeah because it's going
to take some amount of time for the
rabbit to eat the carrots well it's it
that basically cellular automatic like
models but they happen to be done with
uh you know agents rather than where you
where you're specifying
if the local environment is this then do
this whereas in a cellular automaton
case in other words the default of do
nothing is much more common in an
agent-based model than it is in a solar
Automotive well I I think it's also just
that that
basically you get yourself into a whole
lot of complication if you if you allow
for continuous time and most new dating
based models are very approximate anyway
right right right but so so then what we
need here is
a
way of representing just like we have in
cellular automaton
you know we just need a way to specify
this stuff where each
where the whole state of the system the
global state is specified by some list
of associations probably you know let's
say let's say
the state of each of each agent
is an association
the global state
is a list of associations
the events
take
let's say pairs of associations or
individual associations take
you know lists of associations
that match certain patterns
and transform them so first statement
um well for transform them I think that
you know you probably don't want to
actually return modified versions of
them you probably want to be able to
return something that they're specifies
what what they're all doing and the
framework will actually mutate them
because again if you want to say
something like this agent is moving up
into the left you want the framework to
to manage that movement so that it can
handle boundary conditions Etc
yeah I mean I might I might be agreeing
with Christopher on this that
there's an overarching framework I guess
and you know it'll
maybe the framework has the initiative
and then it finds out an event is
supposed to happen so it passes down to
an event handler and then once the event
is resolved it goes back to the
framework which then looks for the next
event I think that's fine I think that's
fine but so there's a bunch of
associations that like look like this
and then the I mean all that's going to
happen is
there's a you know uh
you know an action function so to speak
so that let's say it's agent based model
agent based
well I don't want to call it model agent
based simulation
okay which takes a um
uh takes the set of rules
and a state and a number of those rules
are are kind of like it's a you know an
association or something where you're
giving sort of event specs Arrow
functions to apply where the event specs
might be something like you know two
agents are within this distance from
each other or something like that
well that's spec and somehow you want to
be able to specify things also like two
rabbits or within this distance from
each other well I mean carrots and so on
right so this is you know this is a type
rabbit
but again by the way I bet I I'm
guessing position should be
foreign
because you should have this outer
Association that's sort of the framework
one and then you should have the general
property well I'm not sure that's right
because I think that there may be things
that that autonomous only the framework
will really be modifying that run before
the quotes programmer events
perhaps because I think it's useful to
have this Association where you can pick
up oh I want to look at these positions
if the thing is near the uh the lake or
something do this no of course of course
you should have access to the positions
I'm just this is sort of a pedantic
point that arguably the structure of the
association should just be that some of
the keys are in some some catch-all
Fields like properties arrow and then
some Association
and that those would be all the sort of
you know programmers keys and it's
separately they're the Frameworks Keys
we should look at this I need to go to a
different different thing
um another live stream actually uh
actually I believe we're making progress
with this we should try and nail this
this is this seems to me once it has a
design I just don't think it's that hard
to implement
um yeah I mean I think they'll be
they'll end up being a lot of different
cases for like you know like I think the
thing to do is to survey some
agent-based models that are out there
and then we'll find out that they're you
know 75 different kinds of events that
they use
um and you know it'll be a matter of
getting those
right
all right we should wrap up here
um
thanks all and uh
uh yeah
have happy holidays and um
see you all soon I'm not actually maybe
we even have some idiot of it I keep on
thinking that this week is about to be
no I think this is this is our last um
uh
live stream design review live stream at
least this week
so okay thanks all see you all soon
bye